hey leute hier ist eure mal wanne und
heute mit einem special ich wollte mir
so eine deutschland hätte kaufen und
dann war ich beim ein euro laden und hab
was entdeckt und zwar das ist angesichts
tattoo hier steht ja fest
da tu ich hatte ja schon in einem video
lippen tattoos die ging allerdings auch
sehr schlecht er wieder ab und ich bin
jetzt ein bisschen hin- und hergerissen
ob ich das überhaupt ausprobiert heute
aber gut mal gucken so glücklich will
ich später aussehen
ich liebe fußball fangen wir an
wir brauchen noch namen für die ganze
geschichte war wills wissen bei damp
dankbares können wir eigentlich besser
mit einem richtigen gedroht
anne wills wissen
also meine damen und herren
schritt 1 passen sie die maske
durchzuschneiden
die linien in ihrem gesicht größe groß
mittel kleinen hier sind so linien und
da das aus spaß machen wir das jetzt
auch dazu brauchen wir eine schere
ich habe keine ferien
tierische ich habe eine sehr hässliche
schere aber das coupé dann schneiden wir
dran haben und gucken wie groß meine
stirn geht wissen basiert und mein kinn
geht es hier
damit ihr auch zukommt aber schmal wie
das jetzt abbauen man scheiße das ist
vollkommen beat war je so geht's ab hör
auf abzugeben die nicht so ab
sie kann schneiden
oben passt es ja unten auch ich finde
immer noch nicht damit aus diesem
perverser mörder irgendwie ein
horrorfilm drehen
in sieben tagen wirst du sterben war
zweiter schritt gesicht waschen und
abtrocknen sollte solche zweifel wenn
ihr das erkannt habt schreibt denn die
kommentare also bevor das jetzt
komplizierter wird wir gehen jetzt ins
badezimmer und ich mich einfach mal mit
kommt künftig ins produziert wieso
funktioniert das nicht so meine damen
und herren wir sind jetzt im badezimmer
schutzfolie von mehr pappe abziehen
das könnte beim ok nicht nicht witzig
jetzt könnt ihr als serienmörder
durchgehen
wir brauchen einen nassen lappen
der ist noch trocken dazu nehmen wir ein
bisschen dass es wasser teenies
man kann damit gar nicht lachen was zur
hölle ist das hier seht ihr das
ich sehe er aus riesa latex anzug sieht
aus wie uwe 36 geht gerne zu seiner
domina kammern machen also für einen
euro und dann hast du so eine komplette
maske auf was aussieht als hättest du
verlange dein gesicht angemalt obwohl
das man kurz brauchen bald dass ich
hatte etwas anderes erwartet bevor mit
der gesagt wie vor dem schland test
bestanden
geil also ich warum werbung machen aber
ich finde es cool dass aktien warum habe
ich denn schon meine haare aufgemacht so
verzichte das ist gerade fragt natürlich
hat mir ein euro shop 3000 euro dafür
gegeben dass ich die 1 euro maske
bewerbe also ich hoffe doch dass jetzt
die fleißig einkaufen geht damit sich
der ein euro laden nicht verkalkuliert
hat
ein stück und malen es kaputt gegangen
meine haut riecht jetzt nach nach wacks
malern irgendwie macht mir spaß mit den
sachen und ich hoffe und ich geben